We're just about ready to wrap up the course.
We've covered Stratton's taxonomy of parallel optimization patterns,
and we've tied those back to the lessons and assignments that you've had throughout the course.
We've discussed the wide array of libraries
that let you easily exploit the computational horsepower of the GPU.
We've reviewed a few programming power tools
to help you write high-performance applications with less work.
And finally, we've talked about other platforms, including CUDA support for other languages
like Python and MATLAB and Fortran
as well as cross-platform solutions for CUDA-style massively parallel programming.
So to close the lecture and the course,
we're going to hear about one of the more exciting new features in the latest CUDA GPUs,
dynamic parallelism.
We've invited the real expert on this topic, Dr. Stephen Jones from NVIDIA,
to give us a guest lecture on dynamic parallelism.
We've also recorded an interview with Stephen for those of you interested
in diving a bit deeper afterwards.
So let's turn it over to Stephen, then we'll wrap up the course.